what i want to do in this video is talk
a little bit more about the concept of
an organelle
organelle
and as you can see it contains the word
organ and that's because the idea of an
organelle is related to the idea of an
organ if you're talking about a human
being if you're talking about me i have
a liver a liver is an organ i have lungs
i have a heart these are substructures
of sal
similarly similarly
an organelle is a substructure of the
cell
sub structure you could view it as a
almost an organ of the cell sub
structure
structure
of the cell and actually let me be a
little bit more particular there
membrane bound cell membrane brown
structure of cell
membrane
membrane
bound
structure of cell so for example let me
draw a cell so that is my cell right
over here
we're already familiar with the idea of
a nucleus a nucleus is a membrane a
membrane membrane
bound structure so it is in it is an
organelle nucleus we've talked about the
endoplasmic reticulum
which is also an m a
a membrane bound structure so it is also
an organelle
we have talked about golgi bodies
we have talked about golgi bodies once
again membrane membrane bound structures
so it is also an organelle so that's
golgi
golgi body
right over there
we have a
we have the endoplasmic reticulum right
over there and by this definition even
these small little vesicles these little
membranes that are carrying things
around even these vesicles could be
considered to be organelles
vesicle
and if you have really large vesicles or
a bunch of these vesicles fused together
you have these larger membrane-bound
structures called vacuoles which are
really could just be really viewed as
large vesicles or a bunch of vesicles
fused together
vacuoles
vacuoles all of these things these are
all membrane bound structures
inside the cell and so these are all
considered organelles
now some people are a little bit more
particular when they really talk about
organelles they say okay you know we
could say maybe membrane membrane-bound
structures but there are some organelles
that are not only membrane bound but
they also have their own dna
for example
for example you have mitochondria which
i will do in pink
you have mitochondria which exist in
most eukaryotes
and this is really the energy producing
i guess you could say the the energy
factory of the cell
mito
let me draw it like this it has a
has an inner and outer membrane so that
right over there is mitochondria where
the energy
it really takes sugars and is able to
take that sugar chemical energy and turn
into atp which i guess is still chemical
energy but a more useful or more a more
readily used form of energy mito
mitochondria
in plants you have plastids
so in plants
you have plastids and the most famous or
at least from our point of view the most
famous of these
are chloroplasts where photosynthesis
takes place where you're taking light
energy and turning that into chemical
energy in the form of sugars so this
right over here this is a chloroplast
let me
we go into much more detail about with
those when we talk about photosynthesis
so that right over there a chloroplast
which is which is a more which is a more
particular form of a plastid so i just
drew a chloroplast
chloroplast
but that's a more particular form of a
plastid
it also it also has its own dna
and so mitochondria and chlora and
plastids generally are are fascinating
because it is believed because they have
their own dna and they can they can
replicate themselves that it's believed
that they that their ancestors were once
independent
prokaryotes and at some point these
independent prokaryotes started to get
together and into a membrane brown
structure started to work together in
symbiosis
and that though that kind of that
collaborative of these prokaryotes
working together
is believed to be the predecessor of say
a
modern many modern cells that contain
these structures so it's a really
fascinating window into how these things
actually might have formed but the big
picture here that i just want to make
sure we understand is an organelle is
really it's it's generally viewed as any
membrane-bound structure anything as
simple as a vesicle all the way to
something that has its own dna like
mitochondria
or plastids